so this year we busted all out for the
fashion shoot for the 30 under 30 we had
them all styled in contemporary black
tie and it just looks amazing the style
director Joseph casitas was assisted by
a whole crew of people we had some
amazing clothes on everybody and then we
had them all shot by veteran fashion
photographer Walter Smith I think in the
end the result was just stunning
compile our annual list of the 30 under
30 in this is the 30 hottest most
amazing young people in 15 different
categories ranging from everything from
media to arts and design to technology
to science to health care and these
people are picked up through a fairly
elaborate vetting process Forbes
reporters in each beat category each
area pick three experts industry experts
and these are fairly famous people and
then they work with those experts to
identify a group of say fifty or so
people and they slowly winnow it down
until we have the 30 winners this year
in energy Leslie Duan was one of my
all-time favorite 30 under 30 she's
getting her PhD in I believe its nuclear
engineering at MIT and I didn't know
this but a lot of the energy and nuclear
waste is still in that way so that's why
it's so radioactive that's why it lasts
for thousands of years she's coming with
a process to reuse the nuclear waste to
get new new energy initial results in
less radioactive waste and could power
the country the entire country's America
for a hundred years with no more carbon
admissions another really interesting
story in this year's list is Josh Sumner
he was in our health and science
category Josh was diagnosed with a very
rare form of cancer of bone cancer when
he was 18 he was a freshman at Duke and
he was given basically seven years and
rather than accept that he dropped out
of school and is working to find a cure
for his cancer and in doing so finding a
blueprint for finding and moving forward
the science on other rare forms of
cancer media we had Matt Mullenweg was
our stand out this year and he's the
founder of something called WordPress
and if you use the internet you've
probably seen WordPress seventeen
percent of the entire internet uses
wordpress to publish their sites
including Forbes com and we also had a
sprinkling of celebrities across the
category this year we had Wiz Khalifa
and music
we had Deron Williams in sports the
basketball player for the nets and Kate
McKinnon Hollywood who's the new cast
member on saturday at live who has been
sort of called the new Tina Fey are
these people going to go on to be really
the next great things I mean it's really
hard when you're under the age of 30 to
say or for us to say that these are the
are absolutely the future but I'll tell
you if you look at last year's list we
have a some pretty pretty impressive
people that were called out Kevin
Systrom the founder of Instagram had his
company bought by Facebook for some
obscene amount of money and Daniel ack
was our cover boy last year and
everybody knows how well Spotify was
doing probably the easiest way to learn
more about all these amazing people in
the 30 under 30 is take a look at the
videos we shot
you